I'm Jim huertas former law enforcement
12 years today I'm going to see who's
stoned can you go like this
you can't stick your tongue out far than
that okay perfect why are you shaking
why are you shaking yeah I noticed that
too I always shake that and how much of
your hands like this you have nice nails
too thank you what did you eat there was
a bunch of different things the toppings
I can choose from someone was it good
yeah
yeah one thousand
I do it I'm not really getting valid 81
000 can you point your toe though as
you're doing that there you go you want
me to start over nope just keep going
that's good all right I think I've seen
enough gathered enough evidence my pick
for who's stoned is Irene
well the person who spoke today step
forward
Jeff
it was those damn shakes